l'expression de mes sentiments
les plus sincères et les plus
dévoués oui quoi signer les
lettres est terminée voilà ce n'est pas
la peine que j'aille - la poste puisque
emile campagne le facteur va passer
faire sa tournée il aura la gentillesse
de l'emporter et de la déposer lui-même
dans la boîte le timbre à l'automne
cette lettre est très important et très
officielle très très officiel
je suis gâté kazim hier
monsieur casimir
quasiment toutes les trois sont pour
casimir où on retrouve toute façon ça
m'est égal j'ai horreur de recevoir des
lettres d'ailleurs c'est beaucoup trop
fatigante à ouvrir de nécrose elle est
là sur la table bien lire les prendra
plus tard bien et benghazi les eaux là
je te dis au revoir à demain à rouen
fait facteurs fin pouvez-vous m'en
porter une lettre urgent aux mais bien
volontiers donne là moi avons je veux
être certain qu'elle va arriver au plus
vite enfin comment oses-tu penser une
chose pareille non nous ne vous fâchez
par des acteurs mais je préfére
auparavant en obtenir certaines
précisions refusera vous de me les
fournir
mais non mais non il n'y a pas de secret
dans l'acheminement du courrier très
bien voilà si j'envoie une lettre à
signer
ces jeunes que des amis mais non facteur
signer c'est une ville en australie
alors
dans les eaux si
je préfère noter tout ça parce que c'est
compliqué mais c'est énorme mon stylo
voilà une lettre pour sydney voilà voilà
pour sydney là c'est noté bon alors
est-ce qu'elle passera par new york
l'ordre colombo et jakarta ou plutôt est
ce qu'elle passera par tokyo shanghai
mindanao et surabaya voilà
évidemment a bien réfléchi jakarta où
sur un baiia ça se discute
je vais aller me renseigner je reviens
tout de suite à tout à l'heure oui à
deux facteurs attendez c'est important
qu'ils m'aiment parce qu'elle aurait pu
passer par toronto
simba chelyabinsk team durant gones est
pas la bande
celui là
m'avait l'air bien préoccupé rendement
parlait pas mademoiselle julie n'en
parlait pas je suis très occupé je
m'occupe de questions très importantes
pour le compte de léonard c'est vrai je
vous à bouger j'ai beaucoup de mal à
trouver et bien demandé à françois pour
sûr vous avez raison
tout
françois jeu je ne vous dérange pas trop
nous ne peut pas du tout facteur j'étais
en train d'étudier un livre de
géographie ça ça tourne bien françois ça
très bien j'ai besoin de votre aide vous
qui êtes tellement savants nous menons
ne nous ont pas encore facteur passe
encore mais
voudrait france en passant je commence à
perdre du temps
excusez moi mais j'ai besoin de tous ces
renseignements
et vous pensez que je peut vous être
utile a sûrement viola voudrais savoir
comment faut-il doit faire pour envoyer
une lettre à sydney en australie
effectivement aux acteurs la question de
léonard n'est n'est pas facile du tout
je pense que les affaires c'est de
regarder dans un atlas quoi la classe et
oui l'acteur un atlas c'est un livre
dans lequel se trouvent toutes les
cartes de tous les pays du monde avec
les villes les fleuves les montagnes et
les rivières etc etc ans comme c'est
beau françois et dire que dans chaque
ville dans chaque village à chaque page
il ya un facteur comme moi pour porter
le courrier
c'est vrai acteur je vais appeler les
enfants les enfants venez vite venez
vous installer dans l'herbe nous allons
faire un jeu c'est pour aider emile
campagne d'autres facteurs je vais vous
montrer des cartes de différents pays et
vous allez me dire quelle est la
capitale la capitale est indiquée sur la
carte par un point rouge alors voici la
chine quelle est la capitale de la chine
et pékin très bien telle est la capitale
les états unis chercher chez vous
washington
eh bien oui la capitale du canada ici au
bout de mon doigt
ottawa
voici l'australie est la capitale
chercher chez vous vous trouvez la
réponse canberra bravo
voici le japon
non c'est à pékin c'est tout clio s'est
bien trouvés
voici la semaine la capitale
s'appelle stockholm il s'agit des
facteurs je le savais françois vous
apprenez beaucoup de choses en mouvement
je m'instruis excusez moi je la mets à
l'envers
voici la norvège la capitale
oslo et voilà merci beaucoup les enfants
merci surtout pour emile campagne à
merci remercie mes soutiens facteurs
maintenant il nous reste à étudier les
chemins cris dans les airs par les
avions de l'aéropostale oui c'est à dire
par cela au bureau de poste bon bon bon
bon bon vous pouvez me prêter beaucoup
vos cartes et françois volontiers des
gens voient les recycle bonjour je vais
regarder tout ce que je voulais tout
apprendre par coeur et alors dès qu'elle
a quitté les étendues arides et glacées
de la sibérie qu'à l'être en planant
contourne les contreforts escarpées de
la mongolie mystérieuse et vite on
l'abat temps passe par sumatra manille
les philippines
l'acteur ça n'a pas l'air très directe
comme chemin pour arriver en australie
le lendemain matin enfin peut-être à
leonard seulement j'ai choisi le chemin
le plus beau le plus poétique
parce que vous croyez qu être au fond
d'un sac postal est sensible à la poésie
du pays'' a mais parfaitement une lettre
est un objet sensible et fragile qui
sait se charger de parfums recueillis au
cours de son long voyage
est ce que tu dis
auriez vous je vous écoute amène pas si
tu tiens par exemple voilà j'ai reçu
notre lettre
eh bien regardez celle ci un petit peu
sa maison parfait sans grand bruit elle
sent le grand bruit
ah oui c'est vrai
que
j'ai graisser la chaîne de ma bicyclette
et puis j'ai pris le courrier je les
mets dans mon sac puisque qu'elle est
lointain vient-elle ses pointes quel
pays attend ben je viens de
le vient d'australie
le lot timbre de sites maintien est
inquiète et d'adressé monsieur leone a
amassé toit a donné la preuve en est la
moins ville oui si
forcément qu'après le temps il m'écrit
qu'ils quittent l'australie
alors plus de lettres pour l'australie
non non mais comme il part pour le pérou
je voudrais savoir pendant que je refais
l'enveloppent quelle ville doit survoler
eu être quitte en voilier à lima et kid
ensuite irène
[Musique]